all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with uh the 10
deaths of wolverine which this is
actually starting to make a lot more
sense now so you guys were right we
should have stuck with it for a little
bit longer and then and then kind of
waited i guess about the halfway mark
usually when stories start to make sense
although i wish writers would kind of
make stories make sense to a degree
within the first like one or two issues
but uh nonetheless so what this does
here instead of picking up with like
more more mctaggart or with this
you know fan-length version of wolverine
uh instead we end up picking up with uh
x23 laura kinney and with scout now
here's the thing about this for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with scout
this is gabby so laura kenny is a clone
of wolverine gabby is a clone of laura
kinney
it's kind of weird right like three
generations of clones um or i guess two
generations of clones so the thing about
this is that with gabby she is her own
character she has her own thing going on
she has for quite some time in the old
man logan's story lines with uh jeff
lemire one of the things that was hit at
is that in the old man logan universe
that gabby had some kind of a shady and
sinister past that she was uh sort of
instrumental and it caused all kinds of
problems different things like that we
never really got the ins and outs of
that and in fact jeff lemire and andrea
sorentino had basically left before that
plotline could be wrapped up i don't
recall if it was ever really finished
but we never saw it come to fruition
anyway instead of of gabby basically
being the reason why laura kinney died
seemingly uh what you end up getting is
basically gabby who kind of becomes a
superhero right so it seemed like that
whole concept was more of a reason to
justify one why she existed and two uh
the character arc that she would
experience which is redemption it's kind
of hard to give a character a redemption
story arc if you don't really see what
it is that they're redeeming themselves
from uh but nonetheless it's just one of
those things right so the idea here is
that while they're kind of hanging out
of course they're met by charles xavier
and the reason why this happens is
because as you guys know wolverine
himself he's basically in krakowa with
his mind sent into the past and that's
the whole story involving the 10 lives
of wolverine this version of wolverine
that we see here in the 10 deaths we
don't know what's going on here we
simply just know it's some version of
wolverine and things seem kind of shady
and we don't don't really have the
details or the ins and outs but because
it is a version of wolverine the best
people suited to track him down and to
either kill him or bring him in are
basically his clones his counterparts
right so that's why laura kinney's
contacted scout of course chooses to go
with her and they'll actually grab one
of the person although we won't find out
who that is until later on and so what
we end up doing is basically shifting
over to mountain view california now one
of the things that we know is that maura
is after this guy mr shakledar and then
we know that wolverine's after him as
well we don't we didn't know why but
we'll actually find out here instead
what they're doing is basically a giant
product launch so he's just one of the
many people out there that runs some
kind of a tech company that seems to be
pretty far ahead of like silicon valley
out in san francisco and that's one of
the things i do want to point out here
by and large whenever it comes to like
tech companies stark industries is
pretty much the most advanced but you
have some that are very very very close
despite the fact that he was depicted as
a buffoon in the marvel cinematic
universe in the comics justin hammer in
hammer industries they're not far behind
stark they're pretty close to stark i
mean they're not really able to create
iron man technology in the same way tony
stark can but the thing about this is
that in terms of almost every other form
of technology hammer's not that far
behind the thing about this is basically
the cia right dolores ramirez so you
guys might recall as someone who is
basically working for the cia as part of
their uh anti-mutant task force this
monitoring krakowa wolverine you know
more viktager and all that kind of stuff
she actually tells this guy they have
information that there is a credible
threat against uh shaklador of course
the guy refuses to bail because his
biggest concern is if you were to leave
the stage right now and he were to not
be there for their product launch they
could actually end up seeing a drop in
their stock value and of course
shareholders would lose a ton of money
shareholders would sell their stock the
company's value would plummet even
further and then you're in the downward
spiral of a company or at least a
publicly traded company basically going
bankrupt so that's kind of the danger
when your company is publicly traded
perception is everything that's why it's
kind of a big thing but nonetheless what
you end up having of force is because he
refuses to leave the cia can't just take
him right they can't just whisk him off
because it's not one of those things
where he's like under arrest or anything
like that and technically speaking
they're not really supposed to be
operating inside the united states
anyway so honestly everything would just
kind of be blown wide open instead what
they've done is contacted the local
police in order to ensure that the
entire area is protected and then in
turn when one of the cops comes showing
up they just come blasting through right
i mean one of the guys is like damn that
guy's hauling ass man like is he gonna
stop and literally it's this this you
know futuristic i guess alternate
version of wolverine who basically
starts attacking all these different
guys when that goes on basically like
all these sirens start going off
seemingly the fire alarms are activated
here the whole place panics and
everybody bails right so it's kind of
the worst case or at least one of the
worst case scenarios anyway but
wolverine's like literally attacking all
these guys and basically taking them out
what they end up doing is getting
shakladar to a helicopter only for us to
find out that it's basically been
piloted or being piloted by mora
mctaggart and that's what we end up
learning here that morgan mctaggart was
kind of operating behind the scenes that
yes the cia is currently after maura
mctaggart but one of the things that she
had done which is a stroke of genius is
she had leaked information to the
central intelligence agency that
somebody was going after shaklador
specifically a mutant and so with them
being an anti-mutant task force the idea
likely would have been to take
shackledaar into protective custody but
also use his location in a relatively
accessible place as bait for whoever was
hunting him and then capture that person
and then do whatever it is they were
going to do experiment on them
interrogate them whatever it happens to
be the other thing about this though and
this is what's interesting in terms of
maura hitting it on is that she comes to
the realization that this version of
wolverine that's after her what she
calls the omega wolverine is basically
from the future right it's like a
version of wolverine from the future as
essentially an assassin sent to take out
more emitted haggart and shakladar now
as you guys probably know from our
coverage of the jonathan hickman stories
the the house of x and powers of x and
the far-flung future right a thousand
years from now mutants basically loose
and mutants have for the most part been
all but wiped out by humanity and so
it's not as though humanity would then
in turn send a mutant into the past
because if humanity sent a mutant into
the past there'd be no way of
guaranteeing that that mutant wouldn't
alter history in order to ensure that
mutants actually come out on top and
defeat humanity and so this mutant being
sent here into the past basically means
that mutants have it out for more
mctagging the only reason why a mutant
would be sent from the future and into
the past to kill more of mctaggart is
because she's still a credible threat
and what she does is she comes to the
realization that if this mutant is also
after shakladar then it basically means
they seemingly end up winning that she
doesn't die here in the present she
doesn't die in the here and now that
even if she does whatever she creates
with shackladar goes on to be a credible
threat against mutants so all they've
basically done here is sent back a giant
letter with purple wording on it that
says uh you basically ended up winning
so now we're gonna try to stop you right
that's basically the case and that's one
of the things that hickman kind of told
us to a degree right and benjamin
percy's basically confirming here that
the war between the humans and the
mutants and the post-humans is basically
inevitable it is going to happen it is a
thing that simply cannot be stuck that's
one of those things that marvel's kind
of hit on over the years right days of
future past days of future present here
comes tomorrow like all those different
stories have basically hit this idea
that like there may be a war between
humans and mutants and maybe some other
group in the future but usually it's
always averted what hickman said is no
there is no way to avert that the paths
of humans and mutants will inevitably
collide at some point in the future and
when that happens war will break out the
post-humans are a whole different beast
the post-humans as we know are basically
humans who have basically been modified
right they are uh genetically altered
humans who have basically been given
powers in the end and in the future they
will effectively overtake baseline
humanity so there will only be post
humans and mutants and then eventually
mutants will be destroyed and then with
that being the case all there is is post
humans who will achieve a kind of
technological singularity that will draw
the attention of the phalanx who will
absorb humanity and earth into their
covenant right that's what the
post-humans are shooting for right just
technologically advanced humans and so
because of that while moore mctaggart
doesn't know the full extent by which
the future will take shape what she does
know is the fact that a mutant assassin
being sent to the past means she's a
threat and so she basically continues on
her path right because again the whole
goal of mora mctaggart here is to
basically end the existence of mutants
prematurely so that a war never takes
place between the two right basically
prevent mutants from coming into
existence to ensure that mutants are
never wiped out so that they as
individuals can live their own in their
own lives as humans and then eventually
post humans and so on as opposed to just
being killed which kind of makes sense
if you're a mutant would you rather live
your life without powers or be dead with
powers right which one would you rather
have and most people would rather just
continue living their lives even if they
don't have powers and so because of that
one of the things that happens is where
shaklandar is a little hesitant on
what's happening here she tells him like
turn on the news right and that's when
he sees the broadcast of what's going on
with regards to like this this phalanx
wolverine and all that kind of stuff
this assassin from the future right
omega wolverine that's when she when he
ends up seeing what's happening and then
she basically spills the beans about
seemingly everything she tells him the
whole nine yards right everything that
goes on now the the implication here is
when she says everything she means
everything so talking to charles xavier
the multiple lives she's lived in the
past things along those lines and where
she expected him to to almost kind of
turn against it or to say i can't have a
hand in this instead he's like okay
let's get to work now this is an
important thing because on the surface
and without much detail in terms of what
his inner thought process is it points
to the idea that mutants are largely
just considered a credible threat by
basically everyone everybody sees
mutants as an issue and as a danger this
was really the case back in the day
before krakowa when he just had mutants
existing in different places across the
globe and nobody knew who was a mutant
and who wasn't that was a little scary
for the average person because it was
one of those things where maybe your
child is born a mutant or maybe some kid
and your child's class is born a mutant
and explodes right has the ability to
let off huge amounts of energy detonates
accidentally and then wipes out the
entire school and three city blocks
there was no way to know if that was the
case so it was a little scary that way
having all the mutants largely
consolidated in krakowa gave the average
person a peace of mind at least along as
long as their country was allowing
mutants to leave they gave them a peace
of mind in the sense that they didn't
have to worry about their school being
blown to pieces and you know along with
three city blocks but then it created a
bigger issue because people started
worrying if all these mutants are
consolidated into one location and no
one can see what they're doing what if
they're building an army to use against
humanity right so one fear gave birth to
another and so that's where things were
a little wild is because ultimately
shakur's like sure right let's just do
this whole thing and so they end up
basically working together on
essentially some form of technological
advancement and one of the funny things
that he asked and she really expected
him to ask this was you know like don't
you think this is a little bit risky for
us to be playing god and she said well
if you want to go down that path then
the logic applies that god created a
species capable of playing god so if
anything if god exists and we're capable
of doing this it's because god wanted us
to and so it's one of those things where
it's kind of like assuaging his concerns
in that way and the two of them
basically continue on now at that point
we basically switch back to omega
wolverine who of course is still in the
the whole facility and fighting the
various members of the cia and so on and
so forth and basically overtakes them
but then suddenly he's met by laura
kinney and scout and then of course
dakin his biological son like the the
son of wolverine and that's when he
really like starts talking and actually
having conversations with him that was
one of the elements of the mystery and
intrigue surrounding this guy is is he
just like some kind of phalanx like
robot right some kind of automaton where
he just goes into the past executes a
series of commands goes back to the
present and then like that's basically
it or back to the future rather and
that's basically it really like
incapable of speech or anything along
those lines no like that's the thing
like we didn't really know what the
whole deal with this guy was dicken
confirms it dickens like i can tell by
your scent i can tell by the way you
fight i can tell by the way you talk it
really is you and that's when he's like
we're here to bring you in like we're
here to stop you but one of the things
he says is like i know how all of you
die i know exactly how every single one
of you died none of you make it like
none of you guys make it to the end you
are executed like you are killed now we
don't know exactly how they die we
suddenly just know that they do and in
fact it's interesting because he refuses
to pop his claws like he literally pulls
his claws back in and even when he says
this like i know how all of you dies
there's almost a bit of of sadness right
remorse even some shame in the fact that
like he's giving them this information
not in the sense that like he's ashamed
of spilling this information to them but
it's almost like a personal shame in the
sense that like he couldn't save them
but like it is him it is actually
wolverine from the future and so that's
kind of the crazy thing is the question
has to be asked why was he sent here to
the past right and of course it stands
to reason to stop maura mctaggart before
she can seemingly end the entirety of
humanity or at least the entirety of the
mutant population and so what we end up
doing is jumping to the preserve a
thousand years in the future and
remember the preserve is kind of like
the base of operations for maura
mctaggart and so what ends up happening
is maura has seemingly survived this far
into the future we don't know exactly
how she did it we just simply know that
she has right i mean remember one of the
things that's put off about uh about
maura mctaggart is that she seemingly is
immortal that once she dies then her
life basically starts back over again
but one of the things this may have been
something that was explained and it kind
of escapes me here i think that she's
basically like she has enhanced
longevity right like she is immortal in
terms of age she's like once her mutant
power kicks in she'll never die of old
age right she'll just keep on living and
living and living until she dies by some
former fashion now again that's just the
nature of her it's almost like she's an
external one thing to keep in mind is
remember just because a mutant's
immortal does not mean they're
invulnerable the two are not mutually
exclusive they're two separate things
right invulnerability and immortality
are not the same but like where
wolverine basically meets up with her
apparently he's been chasing her all
this time and he finally catches up with
her right and it's like you know why
like you know why
why he's like i've been waiting to find
out like why all this had to come to
pass in the first place and she's like
then you have your answer right it's me
i'm the reason why all this happened and
she's like i've been waiting too right
i've been waiting to see the look on
your face right i've been waiting you
waiting for you to find me so i can see
the look on your face when i finally
kill the last mutant on the face of the
planet right but basically wolverine is
the last one now what this represents
here seemingly is a turning point that
is entirely possible that if things are
done correctly this future could
actually be averted hickman told us it
can't but hickman's no longer in charge
of the x-men anymore so it's one of
those instances where marvel could just
change what hickman said and be like
actually guys the war can't be stopped
right the day can be saved and that's
basically it we don't fully know but i
will say that while it took us getting
to really like three issues to get to
this point this story is getting really
really cool
so with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace